قالت مديره الاستخبارات الوطنيه الامريكيه
عبر الهينز طرفي الصراع في السودان
يسعياني للحصول على دعم خارجي واضافت في
جلسه استماع امام لجنه القوات المسلحه في
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكيه ان ذلك يمكن ان
يزيد من حده الصراع ورجحت استمرار القتال
لان كل طرف يعتقد ان بامكانه الانتصار كما
قالت
تقديرنا ان القتال في السودان بين القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع من
المحتمل ان يستمر لان كلا الجانبين
يعتقدان ان بامكانهم الانتصار عسكريا وان
لديهما القليل من الحوافز للجلوس الى
طاوله المفاوضات يسعى كلا الجانبين الى
مصادر خارجيه للدعم وهذا الامر في حال نجح
فمن المرجح ان يزيد من حده الصراع ويخلق
احتماليه اكبر لانتشار التحديات في
المنطقه كما ان القتال ادى الى تفاقم
الاوضاع الانسانيه المتلديه في السودان ما
اجبر منظمات الاغاثه على تقليص عملياتها